today on the matt well show marriage
rates in our country are plummeting to
historic lows this is partly due to the
fact that the modern dating scene is a
miserable despair inducing train wreck
we'll try to sift through the rubble
today and figure out what has gone so
wrong exactly also protesters across the
world marched against vaccine mandates
on sunday and more people on the center
left are finally coming out against
draconian coveted policies two years
later is it too little too late or
should we welcome these converts with
open arms plus is war with russia on the
horizon and our daily cancellation we'll
discuss the democratic lawmaker who
tried to dunk on pro-lifers only to have
it backfire in hilarious fashion we'll
talk about all that and more today on
the matt wall show
[Music]
i know some of you are sleeping on some
saggy old mattresses at night and you
deserve better than that so give
yourself an upgrade helix sleep has a
quiz that takes just two minutes to
complete and it matches your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you if you like a mattress
that's really soft or firm if you sleep
on your side or your back or your
stomach or you sleep really hot with
felix there's a specific mattress for
each and everybody's unique taste just
go to helixsleep.com walsh take their
two minute sleep quiz and they'll match
you to a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life
they have a 10 year warranty and you get
to try it out for a hundred nights risk
free they'll even pick it up for you if
you don't love it but i guarantee you
will it really is it's as easy as that
right now helix is offering up to 200
off and free pillows with all mattress
orders for our listeners at helix sleep
dot com slash walsh that's helix sleep
dot com slash walsh for 200 off your
mattress order
as a married man you know i look at the
modern dating scene like someone who ran
out of a burning building seconds before
it collapsed somebody on twitter
recently said that married people these
days must feel like they caught the last
chopper out of nom
and perhaps that's the better analogy
whichever image you prefer the point is
that i wake up every day grateful to be
married mostly because you know i love
my wife and my family but also because
i simply could not be a single man
in this environment i would have already
become a monk or a hermit in the woods
by now
i don't say this to rub it in the faces
of people in the audience who are single
i say it more as encouragement really
for any who are married because even if
you're struggling in your marriage even
if you and your spouse have hit hard
times
consider that the alternative is to
wander alone
in this barren wasteland
realize that all you have is each other
out there it's dark and cold and you'll
likely die shivering and alone
so your marriage is your shelter be
grateful for it
stop screwing it up
do you really want to start over again
in this environment would you really
prefer to be out there dating during the
zombie apocalypse again i'm not trying
to make single people feel bad it's more
that i'm commiserating with you
now many of the problems with modern
dating and with modern culture in
general and dating in general were
highlighted by a recent viral phenomenon
which began on tick-tock as they often
do and then spread like herpes to other
social media platforms which is where i
became aware of it from what i can tell
it began when a woman used her platform
to vent her frustrations about a man
that she'd recently met on a dating app
called hinge which i didn't even know
existed until i heard about this the man
caleb
uh took her out on one date
and then never talk to her again
otherwise known as ghosting as the kids
call it now other women on tick tock
then chimed in with their own horror
stories about the man who had quickly
been dubbed west elm caleb a monarch
based on where he works
and soon his name was trending
nationwide he had been doxed all across
the internet so here's just uh just to
give you an idea of what this is here's
a quick sample of one of the video
testimonials and there are like hundreds
like this
but one of the video testimonials that
you might find detailing
the dastardly crimes of this caleb
character here it is
i matched with caleb on hinge and we
started talking
we talked for like two three weeks maybe
like nothing serious i never met this
man like literally just texting
snapchatting whatever
uh
same thing happened everyone's talking
about he was super weird like started
getting very cryptic and concerning
and
ghosted
so he ghosts me we
stopped talking
i
went my separate way didn't think of
this man you know was
nothing really going on
and then okay so i go on my life i'm
minding my own business until
about a month ago
sometime during december
i
see that i have a an instagram
request dm request or whatever
and who could it be who could it be
it's him on his new instagram account
not caleb hunter okay
riveting
that guy told you i'm so glad i'm not
dating anymore with with people like
this this is what you have to deal with
and i'm talking about the woman not even
the guy
now she went on in that video to post
screenshots of the text from caleb where
he tries to get back into her good
graces after ignoring her for a year she
she turns them down and that's the end
of it so far as i can tell all of the
videos are like this caleb is guilty of
being rude and tacky and for that
infraction he apparently deserves to be
doxed and publicly shamed
by women who are almost certainly at
least as shallow and selfish as he is
so there's a lot that can be said about
the lack of proportionality when the
internet mob sets its sights on someone
local news stories become global
concerns
and stories that wouldn't even be fit to
air on the local news or to be written
on a note card and tacked to a bulletin
board somewhere still turn into national
affairs
we could say plenty about that but
that's not what we're focused on today
dating is the issue
and this story reveals it's myriad
pitfalls in our current climate the
whole scene is is one big pit that so
many millions fall into and never manage
to escape marriage rates are plummeting
rapidly and historically in this country
so that as of two years ago as of just
two years ago less than half
of the households in the u.s consisted
of married couples and families now to
put that in perspective in 1950 that
number was 80
so it used to be 80 of the households
featured a married couple was it was a
family with a married couple now it's
less than half
and the numbers are still trending
downward
there are numerous reasons for this
catastrophic shift but certainly one of
the most prominent reasons is that our
social system for matching people up
pairing them off and setting them on the
path towards marriage and parenthood and
real adult life is fundamentally broken
so for one thing
everyone of course is using dating apps
now which are which are different even
from the dating sites of ancient times
back in the early 2000s when i was when
i was single we had the dating websites
and back then you would fill out a
lengthy profile and you'd be given in
return
a comparatively small group of potential
matches to contact
but now those old-fashioned websites
have been replaced by apps which are
much easier to use and to peruse and
most people have more than one that they
monitor at any given time
it doesn't require any effort or
commitment to use the apps and the user
sort of swipes through it very quickly
casually discarding potential matches
based on nothing but a cursory glance at
their photograph
so all judgments are made visually which
already distorts the entire process
because a woman's romantic attraction
is not naturally as visually based as a
man's
and that's how a slovenly ogre like
myself ends up marrying a hot woman
because a woman is attracted to
personality sense of humor intelligence
but little of that translates through an
app
which means that many quality mates are
sent to the junk folder just because
they're bad at taking selfies
meanwhile there are far too many choices
so the modern dating scene is what
happens when every beggar becomes a
chooser
everyone is lonely and desperate for
companionship but the field is so
flooded with options
there's such a surplus that you begin to
feel like kind of like i feel when i'm
in the condiment aisle at walmart trying
to buy mustard and there are 197
different types of mustard and though
all i want is just regular mustard the
overwhelming array of options paralyzes
me and i'm just standing there slack
jawed questioning whether i should be
settling for just regular mustard when i
could be getting gourmet dijon whole
grain honey french yellow spicy brown
white yellow german mustard instead
all of modern life is plagued by this
problem everything is plentiful
and can be obtained effortlessly and
cheaply
but it's too plentiful and too
effortless and too cheap
so you can turn on your tv and watch
literally any movie that's ever been
made
any tv show that's ever been produced
and yet how many nights have you wasted
scrolling through the infinite catalog
and then settling on reruns of you know
the office because there's nothing else
to watch
well there's plenty to watch it's just
that you can't settle on any one thing
because your awareness that there are
billions of other possibilities gives
you anxiety and it makes it so that you
can never be sure that you're choosing
the absolute best option
which means that often you don't choose
anything at all
so dating is like this now whereas
before you had only
the eligible single people in your town
to choose from now you have the entire
internet
you're not confined by geographic
boundaries or any other boundaries
the result ironically is paralysis
now on the complete opposite end of this
spectrum are arranged marriages instead
of a boundless never-ending buffet of
options a young person in a culture that
practices arranged marriages will be
assigned just one and they don't even
make the choice
their families just pair them up and say
here you go
there's far less freedom and far less
autonomy in a system of that sort but it
is without a doubt
superior to our system we would be
happier
every person the dating scene right now
would be happier if they were just
matched up with someone against their
will
actually
of course even after you
settle on a match and you meet them in
person
a whole new set of problem arises
it would be impossible to review the
whole list but one of the big problems
is that if you're in the younger
generations
you're meeting someone who was raised on
the internet just like you
having spent their formative years
staring at screens they oftentimes will
not will not have developed
the kind of interests and hobbies and
rich interior life that could form the
basis for conversation and for
interpersonal bonding
you also don't know where to go on a
date or what to do because nobody wants
to do anything but stare at their phones
and as the relationship progresses if it
does
you'll find that the internet also
interferes with emotional intimacy
because there's nothing private or
sacred between you
private li private life doesn't exist
anymore especially for younger people
people live their whole lives in public
sharing everything with the world
and leaving no parts of themselves
emotionally or very often physically
that are special or exclusive for their
significant other
and then there's the biggest hurdle of
all one which has been standing in the
way ever since the modern concept of
dating was first invented
decades ago but which has only grown
larger and more insurmountable as the
decades have gone by and that is
there's no goal with dating there's no
end point there's no resolution there's
no logical progression
so those women complain about getting
ghosted by caleb but what are they
really complaining about
did they see him as marriage material
were they even looking for a man to
marry i'm guessing not
and if not then their relationship with
caleb was was doomed to fall apart
anyway sooner than later
just as all of their other relationships
before and since have
what difference does it make if he
disappears after one date or if he
sticks around and the whole thing
dissolves after three months who cares
you're just hopping into one car after
another and each is going over a cliff
does it really matter if it tumbles over
the edge after one mile or ten
the whole enterprise is so fundamentally
hopeless and pointless that if anything
the caleb's of the world do you a favor
by wasting less of your time
so here's the reality
there's no reason to be dating at all
unless you're specifically looking for
somebody to marry if you have no
interest in marriage
then all of your romantic relationships
are doomed before they start
you're building sand castles during high
tide it's all going to be washed away
before it can be finished
you're making a series of bad
emotional investments
pouring yourself into one leaky
container after another
it's no wonder that marriage rates are
plummeting people are
exhausted by romantic relationships and
jaded by the whole enterprise before
they even reach 25 years old
because they've been betrayed and
heartbroken and dumped and humiliated
enough for 50 lifetimes
that's what happens
when you take the courtship out of
dating
only solution is to put it back in
i mean really forget about dating
completely in fact
replace dating with courting don't waste
your time on people who have no goal for
their relationship
because marriage should always be the
desired endpoint
courting is the trial period the
interview process that both partners are
undergoing you're interviewing each
other for the job
if you approach it dating that way it
will significantly reduce your options
that's for sure
but as we've seen
that's not necessarily a bad thing
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know as if finding a job in this
crazy economy isn't frustrating enough
now there are reports of at least 36 000
fake job listings in the u.s designed to
harvest driver's license info social
security numbers and more
um it's it's
tough enough if you're if you're
unemployed looking for a job and now you
got to add that that's another worry
that you have to add to your plate
unless you get life lock that's why it's
so important to understand how cyber
crime and identity theft are affecting
our lives every day we put our
information at risk on the internet in
an instant a cyber criminal could steal
what's yours sometimes even harm your
finances your credit even your
reputation good thing there's lifelock
lifelock helps detect a wide range of
identity threats things that you
wouldn't be able to find on your own or
wouldn't be able to detect on your own
like if your social security number is
for sale on the dark web if they detect
your information has been potentially
compromised they will send you an alert
you also have a dedicated restoration
specialist if god forbid you do become a
victim
so they've got all angles of this thing
covered for you nobody can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but you
can help protect what's yours with
lifelock by norton
join now and save up to 25 percent off
your first year at lifelock.com walsh
that's lifelock.com walsh for 25 off
we'll start with uh with this friday was
what
appeared to be uh well on friday we
talked about the march for life and it
appeared to be i don't know what the
official turnout numbers were for the
march for life but uh it was if you look
at the footage it was incredible turnout
as always
as we talked about on friday this is uh
this is 40 plus years running with the
march for life when they get hundreds of
thousands of people out and they do it
also during uh the
you know the the
coldest part of winter
and they do that because they want to
match it up with the anniversary of roe
v wade they they could move the march
for life to to april or may and you
could double the probably
the turnout but these are all the people
that are willing to go to dc
uh when it's freezing cold
and be outside for hours at a time
when it's freezing cold oftentimes it's
snowing it's just sleet whatever all
kinds of bad weather
and that was on friday
and then on sunday uh also in dc another
massive rally this time marching against
vaccine mandates and
other forms of covet-related tyranny
and here we have some footage of the
crowd here's what the crowd looked like
so we're here to rise above that
i think they
also you pan you see it
this looks like even bigger than the
march of life this has got to be one of
the biggest
that's remarkable
certainly one of the biggest uh
political demonstrations that we've seen
in dc in in several years at the very
least uh but the left showed up as well
and um
a rather pathetic turnout even more
pathetic than the than the counter
protesters of the march for life
so let's just watch here's here's here's
a there's a random smattering of some
pro-fouchy protesters and let's hear
let's hear what what point they have to
make or what their uh position is let's
listen
[Applause]
and these remember these are these are
people on the left they would pretend to
be um
okay
they would pretend to be you know
they're part of the resistance they
still consider themselves the resistance
they're
uh you know revolutionaries they're down
with the the system and all that kind of
stuff they still affect that kind of
posture
but
they're they're chanting these are
counter protesters showing up to chant
about how much they love a government
bureaucrat
how much they love the highest paid
federal employee in american history
this is what they've shown up to do
and and yet they pretend to be uh
critics of of the system
and it gets worse than that because some
of these counter protesters were even
more aggressive and here's one woman who
um
showed up in a in her van
and uh she she had a more she had a
little bit more to say and let's let's
hear her
going out pay for the police
to shut down the road so that these
white supremacists can party and have a
good time celebrating their loser
president
stop invading our territory go to the
home take your loser president and shove
him up here
white's premises of course and she's got
i don't know what's going on with her
van she has uh she's like a she's she's
literally in a serial killer van with
handprints the handprints of all of her
victims are on the uh you can see the
you can see the handprints on the
windows
of people calling to get out
and uh on her way to murder her next
round of victims she she decided to stop
and yell at all the um at all the the
protesters there because of course
they're all they're all white
supremacists and yet
plenty on the left this is how they they
feel about it and they're they're
sticking to this
but there's been this shift as well
that's happened
especially over the last
you know few months and in particular
the last couple of weeks
so here's a clip from um
from bill marshall real time with bill
maher that went massively viral over the
weekend barry weiss she is a former new
york times writer
who was exiled and sort of
excommunicated
by the left
for some of her views but she's
certainly still not she's she's not on
the right i don't think she would call
herself a conservative
but um she she showed up on bill maher
and she's been getting a lot of credits
from some conservatives for uh saying
this let's listen
i'm done with
yeah i remember read the pringles cans
that i bought at the grocery store
stripped my clothes off because i
thought kovid would be on my clothes
like i did it all i watched tiger king i
got to the end of spotify like
we all did it right
no no we didn't all do it well here's
the thing a lot
a lot of us did do it and then we were
told you get the vaccine you get the
vaccine and you get back to normal
and
we haven't gotten back to normal and
it's ridiculous at this point
i know that so many of my liberal and
progressive friends are with me on this
and they do not want to say it out loud
because they are scared to be called
anti-vaxx or to be called science denial
or to be you know smeared as a trumper
i'm sorry if you believe the science you
will look at the data that we did not
have two years ago and you will find out
that cloth masks do not do anything you
will realize that you can show your
vaccine passport at a restaurant and
still be asymptomatic in carrying
omicron and you will realize most
importantly that this is going to be
remembered by the younger generation as
a catastrophic moral crime
the city of flint michigan which is 80
percent i think minority students has
just announced indefinite virtual
schooling in the past two years we've
seen among young girls a 51 increase in
self-harm people are killing themselves
they are anxious they are depressed they
are lonely
that is why we need to end it more than
any inconvenience that it's been to the
rest of us i think
okay
it's like at this point applause for
that and uh
yeah she says we all we all did this
we're spraying the pringle cans first of
all we didn't all
do that uh at
any point did we all do that and i can
remember
when this all first started you know
march 2020
going to the grocery store
and there's still at that time a lot
that uh that we didn't know about cove
especially or at least there was there's
in terms of what we had officially been
told it was it wasn't there wasn't very
much
um so they were all kind of in the dark
and that's used as an excuse by those
who bought into the panic and the hype
um
even the ones who bought into it for two
years
you know it's one thing if you were a
little freaked out for a couple of weeks
and then you kind of started to see what
was going on
but people
there are people for years that were
doing this but i can remember early on
going to the grocery store and
everybody's in masks and uh you know
people are like at the grocery store
spraying down their their produce and
all this they got gloves and everything
on
and uh
and that was that was back when uh and
maybe there's people still do this where
you're supposed to quarantine your
groceries before you bring them in the
house
you know you keep them on uh
outside for a day
so that the virus dies you know
and i remember thinking
you know
i doubt that it actually works this way
i doubt that the virus is so contagious
that
you have to disinfect your groceries
before you bring them in the house
i doubt it i mean at the time i can't i
can't say for sure that it's not true i
mean i don't really know
i doubt it
but i also thought well
even if that's true like if that's how
deadly and contagious this thing is that
you have to disinfect your your uh
produce
you gotta spray down the pringles
you gotta take out open up your box of
cereal and wipe each individual
uh frosted flake with a lysol white if
it's that contagious
then we're doomed anyway there's there's
just no point in even even trying then
society's doomed if that's the case
so that was the calculation i made very
early on and decided to basically not
adjust my life at all
except in the ways that i was absolutely
forced to because i couldn't go to a lot
of places because they were shut down
but other than that i just lived my life
as i always had
uh and there were a lot of people that
did the same thing
and so now we're listening to people
like barry weiss and um first of all
they tr it's a little bit frustrating
because they try to frame it as oh we
all did this we were all wiping down the
pringles ken no no we didn't all do it
that was you wasn't all of us
but it's two years later
and she's not the only one people on the
you know i guess we would call center
left to the extent that the center left
even exists anymore
uh and and really it doesn't exist
because the left has anyone that's still
on the center they consider you to be on
the right if you're to the right of them
you're just on the right and that's all
and that's why they're going to exile
you as they have with barry weiss but
the extent that she's on the center left
she's had this this awakening moment two
years into it which which is which is
good right
it is better late than never
um what she said what she just said
there is good and important and i'm glad
that it was said
but it is frustrating
um to those of us who have been saying
it all along not just because it not not
just for ego reasons why we want credit
for being right
it's not that it's that the damage has
been done you see
in so many ways
now there's more damage that could be
done if if this stuff is continued
and so it's good to stop the bleeding
but a lot of blood's been spilled
already
metaphorically speaking and sometimes
not not so metaphorically
when you look at the suicide rate and
everything else
so a lot of damage has been done that is
simply just done
and in a lot of ways it's probably true
to say that our society is never going
to completely go back to normal
because of how profoundly twisted it's
been by this and how people's brains
have been
and minds have been
uh
mutated
by living in this environment of
overwhelming suffocating fear for years
so the damage has been done and in some
ways for some of this it's too late
you can't put a mask on a kid for two
years
shut down school do all this isolate
them
for the people that have done that to
their kids you can't do that for two
years
and then say oh i've had enough of this
i'm done with covert take the mask off
and then say to little junior
everything's okay pat him on the head go
uh go go be a normal child again just
forget about the last two years
doesn't work that way
these are his formative years
i mean kids are are
sponges
they pick up everything that's happening
around them
they pick up a lot of things you don't
want them to pick up
you know i was i was driving with my
with my two-year-old the other day and i
missed a turn and i just i muttered like
it just came out i muttered an expletive
under my breath because i missed it i
didn't even say it loudly
and it one of those things it happens as
a parent it comes out it was i muttered
it because i was frustrated and then
what do i hear my two-year-old in the
back
set repeating me and she repeating it
like 10 times in a row
right this is what kids do they pick up
on everything around them in their
environment they're very very observant
especially in their formative years they
have to be this way
you know biologically it's programmed
this way
uh
and so think about all of the toxic
the toxic messages that they have
absorbed
into their psyche there may be no way to
reverse the effect for a lot of these
kids unfortunately
so what do we do with um somebody like
barry weiss people on the left
bill maher you know who are
speaking some truth about about this
issue now
there are some on the right to say yeah
yeah they're they're champions for our
cause let's uh let's celebrate them and
you know put them on the chair and lift
them up and dance around the room
um and then there are others on the on
the other side of the on the right who
say well no it's too little too late
sorry
we got no use for you
i kind of take a middle approach
where i will embrace
an alliance with someone
on a particular issue in order to
achieve some worthwhile cultural goal
i think that's a smart smart battle
strategy
but what we can't do is celebrate them
as conservative champions and that's
that's the balance that we've often not
been able to strike as conservatives
and so this also this happens a lot when
some celebrity what was it with nicki
minaj a few
for a period of time for about 48 hours
a few months ago nicki minaj was the
conservative champion and i don't even
remember what it was but she said
something it might have been cancelled
culture or something like that she she
made some comment in like an instagram
video
and saying something that conservatives
agree with and there were a lot of
conservatives ah yeah let's let's invite
her to cpac
but maybe she should maybe she should
run for president
we'll put her on the ticket with trump
because she said one thing
no the the better approach is that she's
right about this and guess what nicki
minaj whatever this issue is if you want
to fight alongside us on this issue
fantastic
um on this particular issue but you're
not a you're not a conservative hero
because of it
so that's what i would do with this it's
the same thing with gender you know
after the dr phil segment
i have um
i've heard from a lot of feminists like
left-wing feminists
who are
and if you go to some of the some people
send me links to some of these feminist
uh forums and boards and stuff and
it can be funny because they don't know
what exactly to do about this
um because they agree with everything i
was saying about about gender but then
they're looking into the other things
that i've said about feminism itself and
how it's a cancer and like the worst
thing that's ever happened to human
civilization and so they're not sure
exactly what to do but my approach to
them is hey
if you want to work on on um
on beating back this gender madness i'm
i'm with you on that
great
we're not we're not friends
we're not really on the same side
generally but on this issue we can be
for for a particular goal that we have
in mind
good
that's my approach um
one other note on this i want to play
this kathy hokule she's the governor up
in in new york
and
she's she has not yet she's not ready
she's not done with covet uh she of
course is not done with it and she says
hey look the kids can wear masks forever
and it's no big deal because the kids
they they can adapt let's listen
regarding the mass mandates i want to
know if the state has a particular
number whether that be like a pest
positivity rate or a hospitalization
rate that when we go under that the mass
mandates will be lifted or is the state
playing that by you
we're not playing by ear we're going to
be driven by data and look at what we
what our situation was prior to the
mandates
and assess was that the right number to
go back to i can't say with certainty
but that is a starting point to look at
the number before we instituted these we
instituted these we caught because we
saw the storm coming our way we watched
the global trends we saw how quickly
this escalated upward in other countries
like england and south africa and we
knew that could hit us that's why we
took steps
literally the day the first case arrived
in new york state which was december 2nd
and announced these the first series of
restrictions and going up for the next
couple of weeks so
i think about this a lot
i'm not going to operate in a vacuum
we're going to have data and experts and
people who know a lot about what the
next trends are but i am really looking
forward to lifting them i truly am
i know people are tired but i also say
one thing about the kids
my daughter had a meltdown over having
to put sneakers on to go to kindergarten
she got used to wearing sneakers in
school they just
they adapt better than adults do and
i'm really proud of the parents who made
sure that their kids understood this
they adapt it's like wearing you know
the difference between a mask and shoes
for kids at school is that shoes are
necessary
um it's it's necessary to wear shoes
and uh it's also it's also it's a real
safety issue wearing shoes because you
step on a glass or a nail or something
you'll be glad you had shoes on
that's the difference
no kids that
are wearing a mask without complaint
and i've talked about this before
because i've seen it myself and we all
have observed this shift taking place
hopefully not with our own kids i
haven't observed it with my own kids
because my kids don't wear a mask and
and i've never required them to do it
um but i've observed it kind of in
society
where
again early on you go to the grocery
store you go around and you see kids
wearing the mask and they're pulling it
down they're fidgeting and their parents
are fussing with them and say keep the
mask on
and these days if you go to a place
where they're still masking kids
you don't see that um for the most part
you see the kid the kids they're wearing
the mask basically
how it's supposed to be worn and they're
not messing with it very much and they
just keep it on
and you hear from parents who are very
proud of this they say i sent my
six-year-old to school and he wears a
mask for seven hours and it's not a
problem
oh he's adapted
now that's not that's not adaptation
that is um that's damage
he's been damaged he's been beaten down
i used the analogy before of a a child
who suffers physical abuse at home
this is a form of physical abuse and
emotional and psychological abuse
but a child who suffers abuse at home
maybe uh abuse victim gets to a point
where he barely even
reacts
to the abuse
at least visibly you know externally
does that mean he's adapted to it
no it means that the the abuse has
settled deep down into his into his
psyche into his mind
it means that that's how deep the damage
is now for this child
and it's the same thing with the masking
stuff
all right one other note this is from
the daily wire
um we might be on the cusp of world war
iii so on this show world war iii goes
down to like the last it's in the middle
of the show at the end of a segment i'll
just throw it in there
every other show you're gonna lead with
it this is one of the reasons why i mean
there are a lot of reasons why i don't
want world war three to happen many
reasons
um but
you know on the list
far down but on the list is also that uh
i don't want to have to talk about it
every single day on the show
and i also don't want to be the one show
that just world war 3 is happening and
uh and you know i ignore it and we're
talking about dating you know and said
on this show anyway this is from the
daily wire it says democrat president
joe biden
is considering deploying u.s forces to
eastern europe as russia is reportedly
preparing to invade ukraine at any
moment biden is considering the
deployment of several thousand us troops
as well as warships and aircraft to nato
allies in the baltics and um
eastern europe an expansion of american
military involvement and then mounting
fears of a russian incursion into
ukraine the move would signal a major
pivot for the byte administration which
up until recently was taking a
restrained stance on ukraine and a fear
of provoking russia into invading
okay just a couple quick things i'll say
about this first of all
the idea that
a leader a national leader would send
his country to war
because his poll numbers are down
because he's unpopular you know that's
not
by that's not by any means a far-fetched
idea this history is replete with
examples of that happening
there's a long history of that
there's a there's a lot of
precedent for it
so would joe biden actually get us into
a war with russia
because he's sitting at 30 in the
approval ratings and he wants to change
the subject
and he also knows historically that uh
what happens what happens with the polls
with presidents when they go to war
typically they see a boost in polls
people you know kind of on both sides
rally behind the president
so would biden actually do that
absolutely he would
remember for these people the the only
thing they care about
is their own political future and their
own power
and they've also convinced themselves
that that's for the greater good
you know they've convinced themselves
they've convinced themselves the people
maybe not joe biden himself personally
because he he has lost his mind but the
people who are really pulling the
strings people in his administration and
the biden regime they've also convinced
themselves
that
the world needs them there and so
whatever they have to do to remain in
power it's it's really it's for the
greater good it's for everybody's sake
and if that means that tens of thousands
or hundred thousand people have to die
in a war a pointless war that's fine
it's for the greater good as long as as
long as it helps their political future
that's the way they look at it
so for me with ukraine it's it's very i
don't pretend to be um
you know a foreign policy analyst by any
means
but
for me it's pretty simple
um
ukraine
is its own country
and
uh
it's not our country
and so i don't want to go to war to
protect it and look i told you it's it's
pretty damn simple for me
you know we have our own borders that
we're not protecting
and we have uh we have we have
violence and and uh we have all kinds of
we have our own war down at the border
that we're not actually it's really
one-sided because we're not
participating in it
so the idea that we're gonna go we're
gonna go 6 000 miles away
we're going to go six to a country
that's on the other side of the world 6
000 miles away
and send our own sons and now daughters
as well to die on foreign soil to
protect to protect the borders of
another country of ukraine
i mean
you know one thing i've heard from uh
from from people i've talked about this
a little bit on twitter and um
you know i've gotten the whole thing of
uh well ukraine it's they want freedom
and they want democracy and think about
the people of ukraine and what
okay well then they can fight for their
country
they can fight for their own future
that's fantastic
what about the people here
i mean how many maybe we could do a poll
on this
how many parents want to send their
children
to ukraine to die
on ukrainian soil to protect ukraine
how many parents will feel like their
their children's lives were
were uh were lost
in the pursuit of something worthwhile
if that were to happen
how many parents are are would be okay
with that in this country
now as far as i'm concerned this is
europe's problem if they don't have the
will
to protect their own borders and to and
then then that's that's that's their
issue
it is it's insane to me that after all
of this time i mean i get why the people
in power again i understand why they
want to do it i don't agree with it it's
evil it's terrible i understand though
it's it is for them it's really
self-preservation
but of just normal americans who are not
in positions of power
and i would like to see the poll numbers
on this i'm i'm thinking that a war with
russia would be very unpopular and i'm
sure there have been poll been polling
already done on it maybe i'd look at
that but
i can't understand how any americans
could who have lived
through the past several decades
would still have any appetite
for going overseas
and losing
thousands of lives and trillions of
dollars
to protect democracy
in countries that are not our own
all right let's get now to the comment
section
[Music]
and you can always uh leave us a video
comment at dailywire.com sweet baby
comments and uh i don't think we have do
we have any we don't have any video
comments queued up do we well look it's
a monday not everything is
improper working order at this point uh
but you can leave those video comments
we'll have to go we'll have to stick
with just the boring written comments
for today um ej jeremiah says it's so
insane how intolerant their side is they
literally are saying how dare dr phil
not just be propaganda for their side
leslie says dr phil had three woke
pro-trans people against one matt walsh
how was that unfair maybe unfair to matt
except matt one on all points yeah it is
it is pretty incredible to think about
i'm still not quite over that
over that that uh i was sitting there on
stage
and for much of the discussion it was
three against one including a studio
audience really it was uh it was what
you know 70 against one or something
whatever the studio audience was so
three against one on stage plus a studio
audience
that was not on my side
and that is that is really a hurdle in a
debate like this
when when the other side gets all the
applause lines
in terms of optics it's hard to overcome
the optics
when someone says this is one of the
reasons why traditionally in sitcoms
they always have a laugh track
because it's easy you could be
influenced into thinking that a joke was
funny if everybody else is laughing at
it and it's the same thing with a debate
if one side is getting all the applause
and then you make a point and there's
just
there's just silence you make a really
good point and then you look around it's
total stone cold silence
optically that's hard to get over so
they had all of that on their side
and yet
at the end of the debate they're the
ones complaining that they were ganged
up on
you know 50 against one they were ganged
up on and they're the victims of
bullying
it is uh pretty incredible
the other comments is matt you have to
admit that guy on dr phil had great hair
yeah the non-binary you know what funny
enough when i was watching this episode
with my wife
and i don't usually watch my own i don't
i don't usually watch anything that i'm
in
with other people i'll watch it but
always by myself i'll watch it like um
like a football player watches game tape
kind of picking myself apart figuring
out what i did wrong but i don't sit
down with other people to watch stuff
that i'm in
um but i made an exception you know in
this case because my wife and sister so
we sat down and watched it and uh my
wife was disturbed
like everybody else
by the sight of the people that i was
on stage with but in spite of that the
very first thing she said when the
episode started the very first thing
that she made note of
was that the guy with the beard and the
dress had really nice hair and so she
remarked on it a couple of times
raving about his hair
and that is really it's another profound
demonstration of the difference between
men and women because women will always
comment on nice hair
no matter whose hair it is no matter the
situation it's it's biologically
ingrained they can't stop themselves
my wife she could be in the process of
getting murdered by a serial killer by
that woman in the van with the with all
the handprints and if the killer had
nice hair my wife would still take a
second to say hey
sorry this is awkward but you have great
hair what kind of shampoo do you use
it's a good thing that hitler didn't
have nice hair because i think women are
beginning themselves in a lot of trouble
constantly kind of remarking on it
um and then i'm on the other end of the
spectrum because i don't notice
someone's hair could be on fire in front
of me i don't think i would notice it so
yesterday we were going out somewhere
and my wife was complaining that that
her her hair looked terrible she was
having a bad hair day or something and i
thought it looked perfectly fine so she
said i know i gotta i gotta take care of
it so she went into the bathroom
to go get ready and she was gone for two
hours getting ready and she came out and
she was so happy that her hair had been
fixed and she said look at my hair now
and it looks exactly the same to me
so
i don't know i don't know what she was
doing in there like did she watch each
follicle individually with shampoo i'm
not sure
looked great just just you know the same
um
let's see
igor says i distinctly remember matt
saying he would write his own slam
poetry when his channel reached 500 000
subscribers
a few comments pointing that out i had
no i have no memory of making that
promise
i don't know why i would make i promise
to do slam poetry why would i
why would i promise that of all things
what was i drunk i might have been drunk
during that episode i don't i don't
drink before the show but maybe that one
maybe that's why i don't remember it
um
okay
well here's the thing
i said once we reached 500 000
but we kind of blew past that
and now we're at 550 000.
so it's too late i think now
unfortunately as much as i would love to
you know as much as i would love to hold
on my end of the bargain it's really i
said what i said once where didn't i say
that once we're at 500 000 i'd do the
slam poetry
but now we're at 550
and that's why i can't do it
we'll look at 600 000 maybe
you know what a million
i'm i'm we're moving the goal post
let's get to a million
and i will have my own
uh
my very own poetry that i will recite
for you at 1 million
unless i think of another excuse not to
do it
if you haven't already go check out our
new comedy series truth yeller hosted by
comedian and podcaster adam corolla over
at dailywire.com
watch in the next episode airing this
thursday adam gets controversial by
mocking hunter biden and the way that
our overlords are attempting to create
train your kids tj miller of silicon
valley
also deadpool big hero 6 and many more
joins adam to drop some comedy gold and
he proves that he knows how to identify
a grandma killer at the same time so
head to dailywire.com subscribe and use
code miller for 25 off your membership
look out for the new episode with tj
miller dropping this thursday now let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so today we cancel forest bennett who's
a democratic lawmaker in oklahoma who
had uh had what he thought was a
brilliant idea last week he tweeted out
triumphantly
this week i filed hb 3129 which codifies
that a father's financial responsibility
to his baby and their mother begins at
conception if oklahoma is going to
restrict a woman's right to choose we
sure better make sure that the men
involved can't just walk away from their
responsibilities now this was meant to
be a dunk on the evil pro-lifers who
forest believed only opposed abortion
because of their deep hatred for women
he believed this despite the fact that
the pro-life movement is led primarily
by women just go watch the march for
life watch the footage
what about those women well they must
all be self-hating misanthropes he
decided because to the left
the self-hating women are the ones who
oppose abortion you know not the ones
who say cut their breasts off and try to
become men no they're not they're not
self-hating it's it's it's the women who
don't want to kill babies they're the
self-hating ones
in any case forrest attempted dunk
unfortunately for him hit the back of
the rim bounced back out while forrest
fell to the court broke his arm and the
whole stadium pointed and laughed
he thought
that the right would shake their fists
violently and say you know damn you
forest you foiled our patriarchal plot
but instead conservatives all supported
the bill
everyone on the right on social media
they're all saying this is great i love
it thank you
after all our position is that babies
are human beings with rights
and that parents should be required to
care for their children or else find
someone who will care for them
you owe that to your child
your child is entitled to be cared for
we have a lot of entitlements in our
culture today we hear a lot about what
people are entitled to
well here's one example of an actual
entitlement
your child
is entitled to be taken care of you have
that responsibility to your child and
again if you can't fulfill that
responsibility or don't want to then you
find someone who will
what you cannot do is abandon them
or certainly kill them outright
that's our position
now of course of course we think that
this principle should apply to men as
well
in fact a bill that codifies a father's
financial responsibility to his baby in
the womb
also codifies that the baby in the womb
is in fact a baby
he's a person a legal entity who has
owed certain basic legal protections why
wouldn't we support that
forest could only look around in horror
as the people he was trying to anger
with his bill instead cheered him on
while the people he was trying to
impress instead were angry
so a day later he tweeted this follow-up
he said
well this has been fun i appreciate
those who understood the message behind
this bill and those who provided sincere
constructive feedback and pointed out
serious issues with practical
application also a great way to be
reminded that 280 characters isn't
enough for some discussions i'm muting
this now because i've read most if not
all of the comments and i hear those who
came here to help me understand angles
to this that i hadn't considered i also
hear those who came here just to be mean
or condescending and hey it's twitter
what was i expecting
let me get this out of the way by the
way the mean people were all just the
ones who said it's a good bill and they
like it
but that's mean because it's the people
that it's the wrong people he didn't
want those people to to be supported
he continues let me get this out of the
way obviously i'm not moving forward
with this bill as written i'm glad many
of you understood the idea but it
clearly needs work so to actual
constituents of mine who requested that
i go back to the drawing board i hear
you
now what can we learn from this aside
from the fact that forest bennett is a
stupid pathetic little embarrassing
goober who wrote a bill just to troll
his opponents but instead uh trolled his
own side by accident
i think the really there really is the
most important lesson is this um aside
from from the fact that he's stupid and
embarrassing
the second maybe is the fact that the
pro-abortion side
and the left broadly speaking
has so
thoroughly insulated itself so
completely hidden itself in its own
cocoon
that the people on that side have come
to actually believe the straw men that
they've constructed
they're buying into their own hype
it's hard to fathom this as someone who
lives in reality
but many pro boards do really think that
the anti-abortion side is motivated by
nothing but animosity for women
now it's not that they've been fooled
into thinking this by some outside force
they fooled themselves
forrest bennett
thought that pro-lifers would have a
problem with requiring men to care for
their children even though we're the
ones who are always talking about the
problem of fatherless homes
we're the ones always calling for men to
take responsibility
our whole point again is that babies are
people and their parents have a duty to
care for them
so
how could the other side
come to actually believe that the
pro-life position is all just a smoke
screen and our real intention is to
enslave women
well partly it's stupidity and
intellectual laziness but also it's a
kind of emotional self-preservation i
think
their own position
is so morally hideous
and they are so clearly and deeply in
the wrong
that they wouldn't be able to face
themselves or sleep at night if they
allowed themselves to engage honestly
with the opposing viewpoint
their only choice is to make a cartoon
out of us
they have to retreat into fantasy
otherwise they would notice the blood
stains on their hands
and the mountain of dead bodies that
they're standing on
they can't handle that confrontation
with reality
until reality forces itself to be seen
and to be known
as happened to poor forest bennett who
is today of course for that reason
finally canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavel
voldowski the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters matt wall
shows the daily wire production
copyright dailywire 2022.
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia howe for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire